hello welcome to this video playing for
mundo again I'd like to improve on that
earlier game where I've where lost in
this electrons defense and I don't know
I don't like that line for what I think
it cannot be any good he had to to enter
this position with this bad pawn
structure and no know kind of obvious
compensation for it but he plays that
stuff let's see what happens here
yeah okay cannot develop my bishop
easily maybe this okay you can take c5
that could be interesting here okay it
doesn't have any interest in doing that
now you just you just place into that
position and it's okay with having the
bad structure okay so see form I can I
can also shut it down with c4 but not
sure about this
okay I just have develop him
they are not telling me you take only
six now I'm and I'm quitting for today
that's not working buddy go back to f3
what is this you really want to take
only six no it's absolutely not working
takes Queen g6 Queen f7 takes takes Ruby
797 and that's not working at all
okay so that is nice actually
I've got that week see porn to play
against maybe I shouldn't have gone to a
five year
I do need the night there yeah for for
blocking absolutely didn't
yeah that wasn't necessary at all that
that whole business okay what is this is
going to trade Queens here it's hard to
believe the endgame would be great here
okay f5 is going g5 Wow
okay I think I have to do this first so
that I can move the night
fatigues
I'll take with the rookies 26-foot he's
got 95 and he has those this one okay 92
94 maybe T I'm not behind on the clock
that's kind of important especially if
you remember the game before that
neither horse can please see for you
yes see for now that's not good activity
to museum that that's a gift it moves
here for nothing
I got a simple plan fy5 that's the thing
and itit was amazingly stupid and I
cannot do that much to be honest if he
moves at night
I'll take g6 and F pawn moves diagonally
form
and now he wants to try to win
there any way to do this I can do this
and a-five it's hard to do anything from
here I can go to time on here though I
mean the airport is kind of dangerous
maybe I can just gamble with this a
little bit and say the apron is
dangerous I know I'm just pushing this
he's got an attack with Knight and f5
yeah maybe it's just it's just too
dangerous if attack and it actually is
too dangerous
Ashe I really hate to lose against play
like that this is kind of completely
unsound strategically sound plane but he
got away with it again check yeah and
she's like okay
black resigns yeah I just I'm just bad
yeah everybody's just outplayed yeah
the see porn is terminally weak and he's
got no counterplay I just have to do it
right him a night if five is already
giving him too much giving him too much
him Luke c8b 697 and then I'm just
grinding him down on the see porn
this is not perhaps not even that great
but at least he's got some kind of ideas
okay so nervous for me was that was too
cautious or anything I don't know the
engine says I'm just glad clearly better
here but it is it is it is kind of
tricky and it shouldn't be tricky it
should just be over maybe I should have
taken with the porn there that was also
an idea but this just looks nonce just
just doesn't look good yeah it cannot be
bad for black how should I do this
92 is of course complete nonsense this
is what the engine is giving em three
routes see eight and then go over with
the king but minus minus 0.8 again it is
it it's not good there but I didn't play
it right he plays that very resourceful
in this bit position and I didn't have a
clear idea what to do this is I'm not
sure what this is but it is getting
complicated yeah look a eight and status
clearly better and now push the airport
yeah here and he is just his he is
quicker am i I'm just I just haven't
judged just correct him not a 5 rupees
heaviness is deadly
check
anything against that yeah I played that
very resourcefully I mean as I said from
a strategic point of view that was a
very bad game up to this point from
white but you played it very nicely
afterwards what can you do I just have
to play more precisely here I've got 40
seconds more and it
okay now 95 is like the normal move but
it is just much better to to keep that
night as a possible defender and like
something like g4 now is entirely
entirely ridiculous I have their five
square so I can just now easily play
yonder on the Queen side of Queen c4 and
and things like that
he has no play here because any g5 is
answered by Knight f5 and so I have to
put this Knight over to defense and this
is this looks pretty pretty terrible for
what this is why I am there's always
cost me some nerves there because he
just very willingly goes on twisted into
a strategically very bad position and
then I screw it up with with imprecise
defense now okay thanks for watching